hey y'all it's undercat here in this
tire tuesday video we're going to be
using
the plumber package to deploy tidy
models and use it in excel
so i was playing around with a polymer
package a few days ago
and i thought it was pretty cool because
i was using an xg boost model
uh in an excel workbook and i think it's
a pretty useful thing that you could use
um in your own work so what the plumber
package does is
it accepts it essentially creates a web
api
so you can just create a function to use
your model
and then deploy it by using a
api request what's also cool is that you
can
you can host it on your local browser or
you can actually uh
deploy it somewhere else say using aws
or whatever
so we're going to be using the palmer
penguins data set um i really like it
and
i think it will be kind of the
replacement to iris
so we're first going to make a model
so i'm going to call this a tidy tuesday
uh
uh what is it tidy model let's just say
um
excel models we're going to make a model
just for excel okay
so i'm going to load in the tidy verse
of tidy models and the palmer penguins
package
okay and then using the palmer penguins
package we're gonna do
uh we're just gonna grab the data set
which will be penguins
and if we look at oops and if we look at
our penguin status
if we look at our penguins data set we
can see that there's some missing values
additionally since what we're going to
do is basically predict the species
we're going to count the species so
there's three species that are
a little bit uh imbalanced so you might
have to fix something there
um i'm just gonna look at the summary so
we have a few missing values
i'm fine with basically removing these
missing values
so i'm gonna do bf drop
missing values df okay
so first we're going to do the modeling
process so i'm going to say i'm first
going to start uh
doing the modeling so we're going to do
our training test splits so
create train and test sets
so i'm going to do a initial split
df probably equal to 880 so 80 20 split
i'm also going to stratify
based off the species i'll call this
tidy split
oh actually i'm going to set the c2 to
the 15th so
do that okay and then i'm going to make
a train data
so training
test data testing
and then i'm going to make our k folds
data which will be v
fold cv and we'll give it our train
data okay so then we're going to start
our pre-processing
and with our pre-pass pre-processing
sorry about that
um we're gonna first do a recipe
um we're gonna predict species using our
training data
and i'm just going to do a basic
preprocessing so i'm going to do a step
normalize and it'll be all numeric
i'm going to do a step dummy
um all nominal
minus all outcomes
i could also do a down sample if i want
to
and specify say the actual class that we
want to predict to even out the set
so if we do this let's see if it does
that
we can see it's centering and scaling
for these numerical data
um creating dummy variables for ion and
sex and then down sampling base off
species
if we look at our actual um
length we have 333 so that's
um that might be a little suspect for
doing down sampling however this is just
a basic toy data set
and um i'm actually gonna just leave it
as is so
this is always an option so i'm gonna
say right here say
can can account
for class and balance
if you want okay
so i'm just call this the tidy wreck
okay so now let's create the models
we're going to create a xg boost model
so actually boost model and then boost
tree
for the for the tuning i actually just
want to tune let's just say
trees and
tree depth just only two parameters
um it's it'll be a class of oops i'll be
a
set owed to classification
actually boost handles multi-class
classification so that's fine
and we'll set our engine to actually
boost
also throw in a um a logistic regression
i would solve just a logistic model in
this case it's a multinomial
regression but um we'll say
the penalty is equal to tune and our
mixture is equal to one so it's like a
multinomial
lasso regression so set mode to
classification and then set the engine
to glm net we have two models that we're
going to be
using we'll create our
create tune grids
so um in this case what i'll do is i'll
just do it actually boost
grid grid regular
give it the the actually boost model
parameters
um and i'll only specify about let's say
uh
three um three sets so
it should be about what is it six right
nine
yeah two to the third wait yeah two
three five
uh three to the second power i mean um
and then what i'll do is i'll create
also a logistic grid
so logistic grid grid
regular parameters out
and then we'll give it the uh logistic
model and we'll we'll say that we'll use
five levels just because it's pretty
easy
additional set the metric so i'll say
model
metric and then metric
sets we'll just use say accuracy
um roc aoc and oh and then
mean log loss pretty straightforward
metrics
we'll use actually just unpredictive
power and since we have
a little bit of a constant balance we'll
also look at the roc auc score
and then mean log loss is always a good
metric to use just to test your model
certainty
okay now let's actually just tune the
model so tune
models of say uh actually boost
res uh tune grid
give it our actually boost model our
tidy recipe
our grid which will be actually boosts
red
uh our resamples which will be our k
folds
data and then our metrics which will be
our
model metrics and then i'll create
a logistic res
and do the same thing where i'll
probably just paste this in
and i'll switch this to
logistic model right logistic model and
then
logistic grid okay
so then we're just gonna um
run that and while it's running i'm
actually gonna open up my
um desktop i'm gonna go to my title
tuesday project
um and i'm gonna actually create a
folder and i'll be and it'll be a
uh tidy tuesday excel
model and this is where our excel models
will be living in
um let's see here i might also
just start the uh
the the the plumber api
so while it's training we'll just create
our plumber api in this case we'll
just create a new one and we'll say
we'll say what excel
model and then i'm going to put that
in my tidy tuesday place
and then i'll put it and where's the uh
teddy tuesday excel model
so right there okay
so um i can see that our models have
fixed
uh have finished so i'll just look at
our
results so evaluate models
actually boost res uh collect
metrics and then we'll say summarize
equals false
okay and then we'll look our logistic
press
collect metrics summarize equals false
okay uh we'll
find the rows together
okay and now let's actually plot it out
so ggplot
oops actually i need a model i need to
call this a model so
i'm going to say mutate model is equal
to actually boost
and then mutate
model is equal to logistic okay
so now we have a table of all of our
tuning grid results
so now i'm going to say x equals model
y equals dot estimates
gm column and we'll facet wrap by the
dot metric
scales is equal to free just because
they're on different um
ranges and axis axes okay
oops uh let's see here actually we'll do
a geom
box spot there you go
so what do we see here um basically
these models are very similar so just
evaluating roc
aoc we can see that they have near
perfect roc aoc scores
uh we can see there's one outlier um
with the logistic regression where it's
essentially just
randomly guessing and that's uh that's
kind of a red flag to me
additionally our log loss um
the logistic regression definitely has a
lower log loss however has a lot of
outliers
and then finally if we look to our
accuracy we can see that
um her xg boost model just has better
accuracy
in general um obviously there's an
outlier right here
outside of of which is regressions box
plots or
quartiles however logistic regression
has
um a lot of outliers that are very low
on the bottom
so this is something we'd kind of expect
um i would i would expect
xgboose model would probably do a little
bit better than logistic regression
additionally um we didn't do anything
that really pre-processed it so i'm sure
these things are highly correlated
um which could be done where we we could
have fixed that with like a pca
or or just did some manual feature
selection
but that's fine because ultimately i
think an xg boost model
um in the video for excel is definitely
a
more clickbaity and i think more people
click on it so i am fine with doing
xgb's model
so we're gonna extract the results so
actually boost
res um we'll do a show best
then i'll just do it on roc
aoc so we can see how
um there's some ties right so if
we're going right here um these two
models are
are very similar if these are the same
i'm just going to go with a simpler
model and in this case
um we can see our tree depths are the
same tree depth
is the same and then we can see their
trees um
are a little bit different so i think
more trees
offers a more robust analysis i believe
um so i'm just gonna go with the 2000
trees
um so i'll just say uh slice two
okay great so now i'll just do a
finalize
model give it our actually boost
model i believe that's how it goes with
trees uh i'm actually not
too sure i'm needed i might have to
research that up my intuition
is that trees are the same kind of thing
as neighbors where um
with the nearest neighbor model you
generally want more neighbors for a more
robust estimate
so i figured more trees would be a more
robust estimate
um i'm not i'm just kind of spitballing
but just that's just my own intuition to
it
okay so we're going to finalize our
model give it our extra boost model
right so if we look at our actual boost
oops boost model
you can see we have 2000 trees with a
tree depth of one
very straightforward okay so now what
we're going to do is
uh create our final model
okay with our actually boost model i'm
actually going to create a workflow so
that way it can do the pre-processing
for us
so i'm going to say uh model i'll just
say uh
final model workflow
add model which is our xg boost model
add a recipe which will be our tidy
wreck
and then what we're going to do is get
our last fit so i'll say
last fit final model
and then we'll give it our initial or
our tidy was a tidy split
and then i'll do collect metrics
okay and what we see here is it has a
100 accuracy
has not seen that data and it was fitted
perfectly
so this is like very good
results um there might be probably
duplicates in the data set where it's
just like similar penguins
but um it technically did not see it and
i'm feeling very good about it the final
what we're going to do is fit
our model so on a model
we'll do final model fit to
our data set
okay and now i'm going to save this
model
final model and i'll say excel
model dot rd dot rds
what i'm also going to do is i'm going
to write the penguin csv so
write csv england's and i'll call it
penguins.csv2
so this is our modeling in this i'm
going to save this into our
titus excel model and i'll say id
um excel model
sure yep excel model
i'm gonna go to my directory we have
that um
i believe i did i need to save the
penguins so i'm going to move this
penguins
datasets uh to our
folder uh where is it
id tuesday
let's see here where is it excel model
all right
great so now we have our actual
uh wait oops where's our model at oh
there it is
so we have our we have that and then we
can go to excel model
i can uh throw this in so we have a
model and now we're gonna start making
our api
okay i'm gonna delete that i'm
to set my working directory to the
tuesday excel model
where is that at
there you go there we go
and there we go okay
so this is a plumber um api
they give you a little hello world same
thing as r shiny
if i run it it'll start running the api
and now we have it in my browser
it comes with this cool little like
interface so i can do like gets i can
try it out if i message like
hello world it'll execute
and then i'll say this message is hello
world and you can actually see
um what it's doing so it's saying it's
through curl saying like
get it shows the ip address or whatever
that you're hosting on
it shows the command echo and then the
parameters
okay so that's pretty cool and what
we're going to do is basically do this
same thing in a model function
cool so i'm just going to rename this
title and say
excel model
also i'm going to read our already our
model so i'll say model is read
rds and it's called excel model
dot rds so now we have this large model
workflow
right um if we actually look at what is
our
model bits
and then we go our what is it
adeline okay
trying to find what what our data is but
that's fine we can just call it the uh
we need to call in the palm penguins
data set
penguins okay so what we need to do is
basically um
write out this function to call it in
excel
so let's say um classifies um
penguins um we can also do was it
species and then we can do um
so we have our species and i want to say
classifies penguins
like adelie gen2
and chin strap okay
so now what we're going to do is write
out the parameters
and if we look at our parameters so call
names
oops uh how we're going to do this
if we do this we can look at our column
names so let's start writing out
the parameters so our first parameter
will be island
and i'll just say island penguin
lives on and i'm just going to give it
the uh name so
torson person um
let me do a view of this
so we have torguson uh bis disco
so uh disco
what else we have
and then dream okay and
dream um we're gonna enter it
another parameter so locally has all
these little helpers
we'll do like uh bill length
millimeters and it's just like ping
penguin
bill length
then we'll do it at pram uh was it bill
depp millimeter and we'll say bill
uh penguin build depth
make another parameter um
flipper length mm and we'll save
penguin flipper length
i'm just going to fill all these out uh
which is a little it's a little uh
i feel like there's a fast way to do
this i'm not sure how to uh maybe
there's a package i'll make it easier
but
this is kind of how i've been doing it
um
it kind of gives you a chance to explain
the the parameters
um in this case it's pretty
self-explanatory but it might
get more confusing if you have a more
a harder problem that requires a little
bit more domain knowledge
okay and then what was sex uh
penguins
sex male email
okay
so now we have this what we can do is
make our actual
um table or put into our function so in
this case i'm going to do a
island bill length
and millimeters bill depth
in millimeters flipper length
in millimeters and then body mass in g
grams and then sex i'm also gonna
copy this so what we'll make is a little
tibble
okay i'm just gonna do this this
this this this
so we have our island is equal to island
and i'll do as dot factor
island bill link
is equal to uh
bill length and this will be as dot
numeric
let's copy this again let's go to that
and this is as dot numeric
our flipper length is again another
as.numeric
i think you could probably do a tight
eval but i'm just going to hardcode in
just uh
make sure i didn't mess anything up so
as dot
numer rick
and sex is equal to sex
as dot factor okay
um one thing when you're doing functions
in an api is it's basically um
you're gonna have to specify the library
so in this case it's d plier
or table and then finally what we can do
is
our predicts so we're going to say print
we're going to say our model data
is that and then our results or what's
going to output is
we're going to predict using our model
our model
data okay
i'm actually going to load in the tidy
version library tidy
verse and with our model
if we actually do our little prediction
right here
so for example if we say i predict uh
palmer penguins
okay so if we do our palmer
penguins penguins
right um and we say a slice like
one and we give it a prediction so if
they predict
model and give it to uh pawn penguins
it'll give us our dot pred class but
it's giving getting in a tibble so what
you have to do is actually
um pluck bucket
so that way it's actually um returning
the actual value
that's what we're going to do so we'll
say pluck
one we'll say per
the wave pluck is from the per package
right
pluck is from per so we have that
okay so let's just i'm going to save
save this and let's run the api and see
if it works
okay so now we have our get ooh actually
i should change this
so get um we're gonna make we're gonna
we're gonna rename this to like predict
okay so now we have our function we
rename our function to predict
so get predict classifies penguins
uh italy gen2 and chinstrap
we actually try this out in here so
we'll see island
we'll say disco like 150 150
151 i guess 150
1800 and we'll say like male see if it
works
it runs and into an error let's see here
what's going on here
and then boom i've got a little um
colon so let's run it again
uh gets i'll just try it out
uh bisco 150
a 150 150
which is a 1800 and then male
and then it produ uh predicts the actual
um
class so that's cool um
so now that we have our polymer api
let's actually go in
and run this api and put it in excel
so i'm going to open up this excel
worksheet
okay so we're dealing with missing
values right now um
definitely it's definitely possible for
us to um
we could have added into our model how
to deal with missing values but for now
i'm just going to
work this model onto a
sheet with no missing values okay
so first let's actually run our api
again
um and if we look at our get um if we
type in our if you try this out and say
one two three one two three
um mail
i'll do disco
we can get this little um query
so since our uh api is running right now
we can actually just
query this website using excel
and then if you look at it it says ion
equals blank build length equals blank
we can basically swap those values with
an excel value
so let's go we can notice that this
thing is still running
we go here what i like to do is uh paste
this
which is paste it
i also like to do a little insert a
um a a row and what we can see here is
okay this is our main function our main
little link that we want to use so i'll
just do
copy that with that right there
and now um we can see what this we can
kind of see the pattern of this where
it's saying like island equals
this and then you have it in amsterdam
or um
and sign so we can do is just do a
little concatenate
this is an equal
right and then we'll do the same thing
except we want to add a
and sign because we're doing multiple
commands
and we'll just bring it up over there
okay so
now we have parts of our api request
and here is what we can do is
concatenate all of it so
this one uh we'll put this
so i'm doing i'm pressing f4 whenever i
press on these calm field names
so when ever i drag down it won't
change the location and then i'm fine
with these actual values
with changing the location
cool so now we have this link
um i forgot this other one so i'm going
to concatenate this part
and now we have a link what we can
actually do now
is wrap this with web service
and what it's doing is it's basically
kind of accessing this website and
getting whatever is the result
and what we can see here is it used our
api
given the input data from our excel web
uh our web uh our sheet and use our
xgboost model to predict the species
okay and now you can see that uh
you know when there's a tie it'll just
pluck it'll do too but
we can see how um our model is working
as we would expect it um i actually want
to
kind of change this to f4 there we go
and then we can do that
and we can see it's working very fine um
i want to note that you can't directly
copy use this worksheet i think
because the the uh
the ip address will change every time
you run it
so i know this is a pretty quick video
but i thought it was pretty cool
to be able to use an xg boost model in
excel by creating an api
and honestly um in the future i
definitely will look more
into how to make more complex api
functions and
also how to like deploy it to a more
robust
um platform such as aws or even rstudio
so i hope you guys like the video and
tidy on